con una victoria significativa así
calificó el comité selecto de la cámara
de representantes de eeuu la decisión
del gran jurado federal de acusar a
state bank un antiguo asesor del
expresidente donald trump por dos cargos
de desacato adicionalmente para los
representantes la decisión envía un
mensaje disuasivo claro para quienes
pretendan obstaculizar la investigación
y es que para el comité banon podría
tener información sobre los planes para
el ataque tal como lo afirman sus
comentarios emitidos en un podcast el
día previo al presidente y
él dijo que todo el infierno se iba a
desatar y cito estamos llegando justo
sobre el objetivo este es el punto de
ataque que siempre hemos querido que les
wanted cinco personas murieron durante
el asalto al capitolio cuando los
asaltantes intentaron cerrar el congreso
bajo presuntas afirmaciones falsas de
trump de que bardem había cometido un
fraude electoral en noviembre de 2020 la
acusación sobre banon es la primera que
surge de la investigación del comité de
la cámara
se anunció horas después de que el ex
jefe de gabinete de la casa blanca bajo
el mando de donald trump mark meadows
también se negara a comparecer ante el
comité barón podría enfrentar hasta un
año de prisión y una multa de 100.000
dólares y se espera que a sus 67 años se
entregue a la justicia el próximo lunes